welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and this episode
i'm joined by halloween expert Jimmy
champagne how's it going Jimmy
how's it going everyone my name is Jimmy
champagne and today I'm here to help
definition spoil the entire Halloween
franchise now hopefully at this point
you've seen most if not all of the
movies featured and Michael Myers many
timelines but if you just needed a
little bit of a refresher before the
best holiday of the year this is the
video for you that will be heavy
spoilers here so if you aren't fully up
to date with the latest adventures of
Michael Myers then I highly recommend
that you turn off now without the way I
just want to give a huge thank you for
clicking this video now let's get into
our breakdown of the entire timeline of
the Halloween franchise our journey
begins on a cold Halloween night in 1963
when a young Michael Myers murders his
sister flash forward a couple of years
and we join Laurie Strode on Halloween
night in 1978 where she is hunted by a
now adult Myers who has returned to the
town on a killing spree out of all the
rat cons timeline changes and redos one
thing has remained consistent the events
of this film and even in the modern
do-over this still remains a constant
it's easy to see why as well the film is
a stone cold classic and still stands as
one of the best horror movies ever made
it pretty much lays the signature moves
of the series with Maya's being
portrayed as an invincible shadow that
you need to keep an eye on at all times
this film made a star of Jamie Lee
Curtis and began the trend in horror
films of the final girl that is still an
aesthetic today that many movies call
back to you though she survives the
events of the evening this time round
that doesn't mean she's away scot-free
and as we go into our next film we see
how the events of the night still have a
lot more in store Halloween 2 made the
bold move to pick up during the ending
of the original Halloween with the one
take from the perspective of the shape
he recollects his signature weapon from
the Elrod's home before quickly making
his way next door to remind us what
we're dealing with by murdering another
teenager Laurie has taken to the head
and field Memorial Hospital to recover
from the night that she thinks is over
while dr. Loomis and sheriff bracket try
to find Michael Loomis and Brad can get
sidetracked after mistaking Ben tramer
for Michael but we get this incredible
went out of it so it's all good Michael
eventually makes it to the hospital
where he gets to work sabotaging the
cars in the parking lot and cutting the
phone lines after that he makes his way
through the hospital looking for Laurie
and killing everyone in his path Loomis
heads to the head in field Elementary
School and discovers that Michael's
inability to die comes from the idea of
salvador the celtic season that would
one day become Halloween but just as he
realizes it was a divergent all along to
get him off michael's trail Marian
Chambers tells him he's officially off
the case and that he'll be escorted back
to Smiths Grove by a US Marshal on their
way back to Smiths Grove Marian tells
Loomis that Laurie is actually Michael's
sister
so Loomis forces are to turn around and
head to the hospital everything comes to
a head there when Loomis shoots both of
Michael's eyes out before shooting a can
of explosive gas that engulfs both him
and Michael in flames as far as
Halloween sequels go this one is still
held up by most fans is the best one
personally I genuinely don't like the
sister storyline and the change in
Michael's overall look is annoying but I
still love nearly everything else about
it especially the inclusion of Halloween
as a holiday I think that's really
important so I still watch it every year
right after the original of course
Halloween three the season of the witch
is by far the weirdest film in the
franchise with a pretty much possessing
absolutely none of the traits that we
expect from the series
there's no Michael Myers no Laurie
Strode and absolutely no Haddonfield
it's a strange move and naturally
audience members were put off by the
film due to it not possessing any of the
elements of the franchise that people
were actually interested in this was an
attempt by the studio to turn the
Halloween series into an anthology with
each following film taking place around
the holiday season of the witch is
pretty much a melding of the festivities
of Halloween and ancient folklore mixed
with technology and it centers around a
company known as silver shamrock that
have embedded microchips into their new
range of masks that if worn when a
special commercial plays melt the
wearer's head it's yeah it's pretty out
there and if you're looking for stuff to
skip for a more streamlined view of the
series then I definitely recommend that
you give this one a Miss when the
anthology idea didn't work out so well
for Halloween three Mustapha Akkad
decided that the only way to push
forward was to bring back Michael
Myers the problem was he of course had a
pretty definitive death at the end of
Halloween too instead of coming up with
a pagan resurrection scene or anything
wildly supernatural the writers went
with the idea that the explosion caused
by Loomis was exaggerated and instead of
killing the both of them in a literal
blaze of glory Michael went into a coma
and Loomis got a burn or two on his face
on October 30th 1988 Michael is being
transported back to Smith's Grove when
he's awakened by two paramedics chatting
about how his sister Laurie died in a
car crash but left behind a daughter
named Jamie Lloyd Michael escapes and
reconstructs his costume of coveralls
boots and one of the worst masks of the
series has to offer the commotion he
causes brings Loomis back to town and he
spends the rest of the movie hunting
Michael while trying to protect Jamie
and her sister Rachel I like how for at
least one scene it turns into a little
bit of a siege movie like carpenter's
assault and precinct 13 when Michael
catches up with them at the new
sheriff's house and this is where we get
the famous scene where he kills the
sheriff's daughter by stabbing her with
a gun he then goes on to kill everyone
else in the house and knocks Rachel off
the roof Loomis takes Jamie to a school
where Rachel eventually meets up with
them after she wakes up on the lawn and
some local rednecks offer to drive them
to the next town over on the way it
turns out Michael latched on to the
truck but after Rachel knocks him into a
ditch the state police show up and
unload a small militias worth of bullets
into Halloween for ends with a POV shot
of Jamie stabbing her adoptive mom which
seems to imply that she'll be the new
Michael Myers even though it's messy and
the mask looks horrible Halloween 4 was
the shot in the arm the series needed it
didn't have any trouble making its money
back so a sequel was quickly thrown
together for release the following year
and throw it together they did the
revenge of Michael Myers which should
pretty much be the subtitle of every
film in my opinion follows the
characters from the prior movie as they
deal with the consequences of that
Michael is found by a hermit and nursed
back to health and as a thank-you he
kills them Jamie has been admitted to
hospital and somehow develops a psychic
link with Michael which yeah it was
touched upon in the last movie but here
it really makes the series started Jim
the shock she tries to convince people
that Michael is still alive but
naturally they don't believe here and
everyone's favorite emotionless zero
banter having killer comes back
to town Michael Lacey to the cast of
characters and we get an awesome return
of dr. Loomis who uses Jamie as bait to
lure her uncle out there's even a moment
where the murderous mutuality err Loomis
has a stroke of good luck and survives
once more and it all ends with the
mysterious man in black no Will Smith
who shows up to kidnap Jamie and free
Michael which segues into the next film
Halloween six is where the series really
started to go off the rails at least for
me it came out of full six years after
Halloween five and despite being a
direct follow-up its visual identity and
tone are so different that it doesn't
feel connected at all after the events
of Halloween five Jamie and Michael are
taken by the man in black who randomly
shows up throughout its story it turns
out he's the leader of a pagan cult who
has Jamie impregnated oh and while the
movie never comes out and says it it's
heavily implied that the baby's dad is
Michael Myers which I guess makes him
uncle dad I don't really like that twist
anyway Jamie manages to escape with her
baby and then she calls into a radio
show to beg for help after that she
hides her baby at a bus stop right
before being killed by Michael
thankfully and now retired dr. Loomis
hears her radio broadcast and heads out
to head in field to kill Michael again
of course things get majorly complicated
from there with Laurie's relatives
living in the Myers house Tommy Doyle
coming back and being played by Paul
Rudd and a totally bizarre third act the
weirdest thing about Halloween six
though is that it actually has two
different cuts which are slightly
different from each other the theatrical
cut ends with Tommy beating the [ __ ] out
of Michael with a pipe and Loomis
theoretically dying off screen and the
producers cut ends with Tommy putting a
circle of rocks around Michael which
stops him dead in his tracks
there is a weird twist involving dr.
Wynn switching places with Michael so he
can escape but this time we find out
that Loomis's scream is due to him
growing a thorn tattoo and realizing
that he's cursed to take care of Michael
for the rest of his life no matter which
one you watch Halloween 6 is a complete
mess and it's a total bummer that it's
the last time we ever saw Donald
Pleasance on screen still it has a good
sense of fall atmosphere and both
versions have their fair share of
quality kills up next is Halloween h2o
which completely washed most of the
timeline making it so that the only two
films that ever happened were
wean and Halloween to the creators at
this point got into deep with all the
unneeded mythology and it was time to
wave it goodbye sob sorry for the bad
puns always remember them having a weird
allusion to water in the title even
though it has absolutely nothing to do
with the movie I'm sorry I just couldn't
resist anyway what the title does mean
that is that this is 20 years since the
first film so we had to come up with
some crappy wordplay that doesn't really
work but sounds cool now the film itself
isn't all that bad and whilst it
definitely suffers from trying to adopt
some of the tropes from the new wave of
slasher horrors that were on the rise in
the 90s most notably scream it's still a
fun ride that's a great time capsule of
the decade back when this was made you
couldn't just block people on social
media so we learned that Laurie in fact
faked her death in order to avoid
Michael and she began working as a
headmistress at a boarding school and
has a son named Jonah played by Josh
Hartnett as per the reboots in the
franchise Laurie is worried that Michael
will return and not one to miss out on
using his Halloween costume for the 70th
time Michael pops up to do some more
killing it's what you've come to expect
but the film takes a sharp turn at the
end when Laurie kidnaps Michael's body
from the coroner's van traps him and
cuts his head off with an axe killing
him outright forever he's never coming
back
nah there's no way you can bring him
back he's got no head he's got
absolutely no head there's no way right
remember when I said Halloween 6 wasn't
the worst movie in the franchise that
honor goes to Halloween resurrection
instead of setting trends for the
slasher genre to follow Halloween
resurrection was content being an over
produced mix of The Blair Witch Project
and screen it starts out by retconning
the awesome ending of h2o and finally
putting Laurie Strode to rest on screen
by doing a laughable body swap after
that the plot jumps ahead three years
and introduces us to two TV producers
played by Busta Rhymes and Tyra Banks
they hire a group of archetypal college
kids to star in a Halloween night twitch
broadcast in the Myers House of course
Michael shows up and starts murdering
the contestants and it just gets more
ridiculous from there halloween
resurrection not only has one of the
worst
asks in the entire franchise but it ends
with Busta Rhymes beating Michael to
death and leaving him to burn once again
at this point the series was starting to
feel really tired so it went into hiding
for a few years before coming back again
thanks to Rob Zombie the Halloween
remake has Rob Zombie style all over it
from the very first scene with Michael
pretty much getting a fully fleshed out
backstory that showcases what things
were like before he decided to become a
mass murderer though the plot is very
similar to the 1978 original it expands
on the law by showing Michael's
childhood being full of bullies and a
Beautif stepdad and a haircut that would
make Kurt Cobain jealous this pretty
much shows everything his school life
relationship with others and all of the
treatment that he goes through in the
asylum those that like the mystery of
Michael will probably find it a bit too
much information but audience members
that want to know more will lap this up
there's a real for lack of a better word
dirtiness to the film and even dignified
characters like dr. Loomis had a certain
edge to them he gets a far more expanded
role and has played brilliantly by
Malcolm McDowell who examines the true
heart of the character rather than
painting Michael out as the boogeyman
this movie tries to understand what made
him that way and it's a real
psychological study of what makes
someone commit evil acts he kills
animals stalks people lashes out at
those that have wronged him in order to
get revenge and as far as
characterizations go this is the deepest
look into the characters mind that we've
ever had however the film is still
beholden to the tropes that made a
series what it is and there's ultimately
a lot of rehashing of the iconography of
the first movie the score from the first
film is reused and in the end this boils
down to a battle between Laurie and
Michael on Halloween night a couple of
teens die couple of people fall over you
know the gist by now but the style of
the film really elevates this movie if
you're looking for an entry point to the
franchise this might be worth picking up
over the original but in terms of those
who loved that first film I don't think
this will measure up for you
Rob Zombie's Halloween 2 is definitely
an interesting movie the problem is it
isn't really a Halloween movie a year
after the events of his first movie
Laurie is living with the brackets and
she's a completely different person
she's in therapy and she's gone from
being the good girl
on Halloween to a trashy goth who works
in a record store dr. Loomis is also
completely different in this movie he
uses the killing spree from the first
one as a jumping-off point for his
career and he writes another book all
about Michael but he has a total
character shift that basically turns him
into a massive douchebag Michael decides
to become a homeless person but since
Rob Zombie needs his wife to be a major
character in every movie he makes her
ghost essentially becomes the mrs.
Voorhees - Michaels Jason he heads back
to Head & field to finish what he
started now I'll admit there are some
good kills in this movie but since
Michael has a motivation he's not really
the absence of character he's supposed
to be on top of that by the end of the
movie half his mask is missing so it's
hard to see him as the shape from that
point forward I like that it explores
the trauma of the events the first movie
inflicted upon Laurie and the director's
cut definitely fills in a lot of the
frustrating gaps but overall it's a
disappointing entry in the series that
we probably have to thank for the
excellent reboot / sequel that came out
last year Halloween 2018 was a big shot
in the arm for the franchise and whilst
I don't think that unnecessarily knocks
out of the park that least puts the
building blocks in place that allow for
some course correction in the franchise
the film completely wipes all of the
events that happened outside of the
first film and states that Michael was
captured on the night of 1978 and placed
in an insane asylum where he was studied
Laurie Strode aware that he will one day
get out because she's probably seen all
the movies has spent four years
preparing for his return and has had
several failed marriages and fall outs
with a child and grandchild because of
her obsession with the killer however it
turns out to be warranted when Michael
does indeed return and Halloween
brilliantly retried several similar
circumstances that we saw play out in
the first film but with the roles
flipped the movie has one of the best
one-shot takes in it that I've ever seen
and there's a real return to form here
with the movie delivering one of the
best arcs in the entire series Halloween
is a great film and if we had to reboot
the entire universe just to get this
then it certainly feels worth it
Halloween kills is the upcoming direct
sequel to Halloween 2018 we don't know a
whole lot about it just yet but thanks
to some pictures that have been released
from the set we know it'll at least
start at the end of Halloween 2018 with
Laurie being taken ahead and filled
Memorial Hospital which is a pretty
Halloween - based on the ending of
Halloween 2018 it'll be interesting to
see how Michael Myers managed to survive
but this time going on a murder spree is
going to be even tougher for him since
Tommy Doyle sheriff Brackett Lindsay
Wallace and Marion chambers are all
coming back as adults it's definitely
safe to say he'll make it out of this
one - though since a direct sequel
called Halloween ends has also been
announced to release in 2021
thanks again the definition for inviting
me to help out with this video it was a
ton of fun rewatching all the Halloween
movies for it and I hope it inspired you
to go watch them for yourself anyway
guys my name is Jimmy champagne and I'll
see you in the next one
huge Thank You Jimmy I genuinely
genuinely massively appreciate you
taking the time to watch all these
movies again just to be part of this
video you're welcome back any time just
kidding you're blocked now if you enjoy
this video then please give it a thumbs
up and head over to Jimmy's channel for
every update on the upcoming Halloween
movie I'll leave that linked in the
description below and if you want
something else to watch then make sure
you check out my breakdown of Michael
Myers which would be linked at the end
we go over the characters entire history
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you enjoyed this video if you want to
come chat to me after this and make sure
you follow me on twitter at definition
whitey or head over to my discord server
which you'll be linked in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with all the
latest videos on the channel so
hopefully I see you over there very soon
we're also giving away a free copy of
the Marvel phase 3 part 1 box set and
blu-ray which contains Civil War Doctor
Strange homecoming or Ragnarok and more
and all you have to do to be in with a
chance of winning is like the video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the Halloween
timeline in the comment section below
but one it's gonna be chosen on the 15th
of November and the Celt be shipped out
from then - ever gets the prize it's the
best of luck to everyone who takes part
this is the channel for people who were
mad into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time take care
peace
[Music]